this
russell wilson thing and let me tell you
the latest i'll peel back the curtain
and i'll be candid
i always am but i'm going to be more
candid than usual because i'm in the
process of trying to find out the answer
to one question
and i posed this question earlier today
to someone
who usually gets back to me
fairly quickly now there's a chance that
this person just hasn't noticed the text
message there's a chance this person has
better things to do than respond to me
but again my history and the habit has
been
question
gets answered
question gets answered
question i posed today that is yet to be
answered several hours after the fact is
whether or not russell wilson has asked
for a trade
silence in response to that question
which intrigues the hell out of me you
know after you text someone and you're
anxious to see what the answer is going
to be you check your phone you'll wait
you see if you're getting the three dots
those damn three dots which are are both
tantalizing and aggravating and nothing
i've gotten nothing
and it's been five or six hours shireen
so
i'm starting to wonder
has there been a communication behind
the scenes that
that people aren't ready to acknowledge
publicly yet yet that russell wilson has
made the same kind of request that
desean watson has in houston
well this spiraled out of control
quickly mike i you know we saw the aaron
rodgers thing immediately after the
season got over and then he kind of
clarified a day or two or later and that
kind of sort of cleared itself up it
didn't
go on and on and on like this one has
and i think this is gonna go on for a
while because i it does very much feel
like to me that russell wilson has one
foot out of the door and as you pointed
out it's gonna be really hard to do a
trade right now
but they could do it after june 1 in
which case he would be gone but no
matter this just certainly feels like he
is leaving seattle at some point whether
it's this year or after this year
and and really what they also could do
now because we've seen in recent years
the practice of working out the
agreement pre-start of the league year
we have a pending deal for almost two
weeks now between the rams and the lions
for jared goff matthew stafford and some
picks flowing from la to detroit that
becomes official on march 17. but what
happens in the interim everybody acts
like it's a done deal my guess is jared
goss talking to the lions regularly or
although there are some limits on how
much communication there can be in the
offseason but
my guess is he's gotten his hands on a
playbook if they put one together and
same thing for the rams matthew stafford
probably has the rams playbook but
uh that same mentality can apply to a
deal that won't be processed until june
2. if the seahawks are fine with it if
the new team is fine with it then you do
the deal with the understanding that it
becomes official on june 2 and what
happens after that russell wilson is
regarded widely as a member of that new
team even though the deal doesn't get
reduced to writing and communicated to
the league office until the day after
you would divide the cap charge it would
go from 39 million in dead money hitting
the cap this year for the seahawks down
to 13 million this year 26 million next
year and given that the pandemic's going
to do something to the salary cap this
year and we assume it will go down
there's a chance i guess that they will
get these new deals in place for
broadcast rights and they'll move enough
money around to keep it close to 198 or
195 or anything more than 180 but
regardless there's benefit to having
that cap charge only 13 million that
that's another way to do it and russell
wilson can start working out with the
receivers tight ends running backs from
his new team they work out on their own
anyway guys from different teams work
out together all the time that's the way
it could go down and then he officially
becomes a seahawk or not a seahawk on
june 2. and what about the off-season
program there's no indication there's
going to be one
so
he's not going to really miss anything
there either
yeah and he does have a no trade clause
mike so he in some sense is going to get
a chance to decide where he goes if he
wants to go somewhere if he has indeed
requested a trade and i know the
seahawks will resist there's been no
indications that the seahawks are trying
to trade him but teams certainly are
calling i mean we know that it's it's
obvious when when a guy
expresses his unhappiness as russell
wilson has that teams are going to call
about his availability and he started
this mike this is not something that's
media generated he started this with his
first interview on dan patrick he had a
chance to squash it in his interviews
with the local media that came after he
won man of the year that didn't happen
he did the gq interview tomorrow he does
the ellen show so he's had every chance
to to nip this in the bun say
no no no i'm not asking for a trade i'm
coming back to the team et cetera et
cetera and he hasn't done that which
totally leads to this speculation that
he does want to move on he's had a
chance to end this conversation and he
hasn't done it yet we'll see what he
says tomorrow on the ellen show
the ellen show is fascinating because
when russell wilson does non-sports
shows there's a history there of
to the host
a specific question about which the host
probably wouldn't be aware to ask and i
recall a couple of years ago before
russell wilson got his latest contract
extension from the seahawks he was on
jimmy fallon and fallon asks the
question about the possibility of
russell wilson becoming the highest paid
player in nfl history when he gets his
new contract and
that was kind of odd like that doesn't
seem like something that would bubble up
to the top of the stack when it's time
to come up with russell wilson questions
and sims has always been very skeptical
that someone from wilson's camp planted
that question to jimmy fallon and it
just makes you wonder what kind of
questions will be planted or suggested
or just mentioned for ellen degeneres to
ask russell wilson along the lines of
his future with the seattle seahawks and
it's out there broadly enough now that
you really don't need to nudge
her in any way to get her to ask what
what's going on here are you going to be
a seahawk in 2021 but it could be
there's something beyond the obvious
that they want to have asked to push
this thing to the next level because
sharing the more i think about it the
things that russell wilson is unhappy
about now these are things that aren't
new i think these are things he's dealt
with that he's tolerated and so these
things that he didn't have a problem
with before he's got a big problem with
now because he wants out and you need to
have reasons for wanting out or you look
like you're being selfish unreasonable
etc
i think he just wants out i think that's
the bottom line but i think brandon
marshall someone's told him exactly
what's going on russell wilson wants out
but he doesn't want to be the villain
who instigated his exit from the seattle
seahawks
yeah that very well could be mike and
who knows like chris sims said on your
show this morning
did he want shane waldron is that who he
wanted as often as a coordinator because
like lashawn watson he said he wanted to
say
in who the offensive coordinator was in
watson's case it was who the head coach
was who the gm was so did russell wilson
truly have a say in who the offensive
coordinator was and is he happy with
that hire he hasn't said either way as
far as i know whether he's happy with
shane walden or not which leads me to
believe that maybe he's not happy with
that hired offensive coordinator so all
these things tend to have bubbled up and
bubbled over and and russell wilson is
now making it known that he is
definitely not happy in seattle i don't
know if this is a surprise to the
seahawks or not but they're having to
deal with it now mike and they're going
to have to deal with it the entire
offseason until something transpires
with the trade or whatever happens
and that becomes the broader question
that i'm trying to get to the bottom of
because when paul allen died a couple of
years ago his sister jody inherited the
team and she's owned the team ever since
and i remember early on there was this
vague sense will she sell what will she
do and she's been even quieter and taken
on an even lower profile than her
brother paul did i have no idea what she
wants i have no idea what she does i
have no idea how involved she is i get
the impression that she like most owners
should do
relies upon her football experts to run
the football team but when you have
something like this land on your radar
screen and you're the owner of the team
and this is one of the most important
players in team history if not the most
important player in franchise history
how involved are you do you have a
preference do you express that
preference or do you just say
i've already been delegating i'm going
to continue to delegate pete whatever
you think is best that's what we'll do
and you have to wonder how much of this
public
animosity and it's not really animosity
it's just public
rank or frustration consternation from
russell wilson does that turn off the
seahawks and make them want
to make a change does it soften them up
to deal with the cap situation does it
make them willing
to find another quarterback because
that's part of the problem if you let
the bird in the hand go you don't know
what you're going to replace him with
are you going to draft someone are you
gonna sign someone are you gonna trade
for someone
and at this point all we know about the
seahawks is according to dan patrick
they're not happy with russell wilson
okay fine they're not happy with him
what does that mean what are they going
to do are they going to tell him too bad
you're stuck here because i think this
thing is just going to continue to
linger until
there's a divorce i feel like they're on
the track the question is when does it
happen so do you say we're just going to
find a way to hold it together for a
year while we plan our options or are
they going to figure out their options
now and make their best decision going
forward and that would be seismic if it
were to happen that would be
as
it would be bigger than tom brady
leaving new england last year because at
least we had months to get our arms and
brains around the idea that it was going
to happen this is something just kind of
popping up out of nowhere
we have so many quarterbacks mike that
are unhappy and so many teams that are
unhappy with their quarterbacks as you
wrote about
today and as you guys discussed
yesterday morning and we started that
discussion yesterday it would be great i
think for the nfl to see some of these
swaps of quarterbacks straight up by
deshaun watson for russell wilson and i
know that's probably not going to happen
so because why would russell wilson want
to go to houston he has a no trade
clause but something like that to me
just would be glorious in this league it
would be so much fun i would love to see
that as it stands now i do expect
russell wilson to be back with the
seahawks for one more year and then i
think the diverse divorce is final
unless
this is the unless they win the super
bowl next year which right now it
doesn't look like that's probably going
to happen but there's a lot of
off-season moves yet to be made but i
think that stems a lot from his
unhappiness is the fact that they're
three and five since their last trip to
the super bowl and haven't been to the
division round and he doesn't feel like
that's his fault he feels like that's
the fault of the people around him that
the team has put in place
another way this plays out and we may
have discussed it earlier in the week
the idea that russell will sit tight and
see what they do in free agency and see
what they do in the draft and then after
the draft is when he could agitate for a
trade that would be effective on june
2nd that's another possible
way that this would happen but i think
common sense tells us that if he's
saying all of this stuff publicly
he's probably saying something directly
or through his agent to the team
privately is he saying i'd like a trade
is he saying the time has come for us to
part ways is he saying we don't want you
to just hang up the phone when these
calls come in and the calls continue to
come in because of course they will over
the weekend one of the super bowl sunday
splash reports was that the seahawks had
gotten calls on wilson but they're
absolutely not going to trade and well
absolutely not has changed over the
course of the last four days and we'll
see what they get offered we'll see what
it takes i think if it's going to take
three first-round picks for deshaun
watson shireen it's gonna take three
first-round picks for russell wilson at
this point so
look
i i it's almost too much right yeah i'd
rather save some of this for next off
season let's not have all this
quarterback chaos now let's parse it out
a little bit like when you know when a
team scores 50 points in a game save
some of them for next week please we may
need them one last point i did a quick
check i know the cowboys don't
officially retire numbers they just
unofficially set them aside they have
not unofficially set aside number three
which would be one less hurdle to get
russell wilson to dallas because i'm
telling you i'm telling you look
all seriousness this idea of russell
wilson leaving seattle has been clanking
around for a while now and the team that
i consistently hear
when the issue comes up is the dallas
cowboys so
heard that again today watch the cowboys
watch the cowboys and i know that would
be
gigantic because of the whole dak
prescott angle but clearly the solution
to the quarterback problem for the
cowboys could be
prescott out wilson in
and uh that would be a huge move if the
cowboys decide to make it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports